it seemed like after ellie's birthday
and everything like you just kind of
went like
dark well that that did
upset me so i i didn't think it was the
place in the time
can i ask you a question mm-hmm when was
the last time you called me
for my you know professional opinion on
an investment property do you remember
the last time you called me
it's been a while correct so you can see
why she thinks she's getting pushed out
no you're jealous that's what you are no
i'm not
that's enough what did you expect dad
remember how we used to get together and
there was no arguing
let's go back to those days for one day
please
that's all just put them off shot
something like what are you
all right that's enough who wants a
burger it's an office he wants a burger
i don't even want to
eat anything i'll have one what do you
mean you want to eat
when my nerves are through the roof look
who's back
call the cops
like i
my son's coming into my house this is
the greeting i get well you're not
throwing the place
what are you doing stop stop
you